all right we're back C celebrating all
things Super Bowl um with Rossy Ross and
Tiki
Barber all right so uh we love snacking
especially during the Super Bowl and uh
anybody here love buffalo wings right
those hot wings and that sauce well I
like to eat from like the pregame all
the way through to the end of the fourth
quarter I like to eat the whole time so
I my recipes are all about cracking the
code on food we love but we can have
tons it cuz it's not bad for you it's
time for a rpe we're up first get the
Roe Tada so what I've done is okay if
you take some frozen meatballs whether
it be for pork or chicken or even veggie
from your local grocery store put them
in a crock pot with some of that buffalo
hot sauce I have veggie ones here and
they cook they absorb all that flavor
and then I put them on a little bed of
shredded lettuce and then I like to take
sour cream and look you draw little
footballs on them look how cute is is
that is this veggie that's veggie for
you that takes some skill yes you just
can put it in a little Ziploc bag cut a
little thin hole what is a football look
like oh I forgot yeah oh my God that is
so spicy right do you want some dip but
you can have a lot more of those I need
it to cool my tongue down yeah that's
what I like about the sour cream and
does it works immediately well they
always say drink milk when you have hot
sauce exactly I love that combo and you
can have a ton more of these than you
can those deep fried chicken wings okay
so eat first quarter second quarter
third fourth and then these are so good
this is what amazes me about what you do
is you never lack texture flavor that
anxiousness that all those unhealthy
foods give us it's like I don't know how
you do it so good I went on a health
Journey I'm down 60 lbs for 3 years you
guys and the truth is thank you I I
refuse to think I refuse to believe that
we have to give up great flavor and
texture you just sort of have to crack
the coat that's what rpes are all about
and I have another one for you okay give
it to us now snacking snacking snacking
thinking about the buffalo wing flavor I
love uh like veggies and some hummus but
what if we put hot wing sauce in the
hummus and mix it around drizzle a
little more on
top crumble some blue cheese crumbles on
top of that hello and then we can dip
carrots or how about celery cuz that's
what they usually serve with hot wings
right in the sauce so a little celery
you're going to get all that hot wi
flavor I love I love blue cheese too by
the way I mean you know what's the best
combination by the way what blue cheese
and honey I love that together it's so
good it's so good I also this is
delicious I'm so glad you like it I also
found buffaloing um seasoning you can
get at the grocery store so even if you
have some like sweet potato chips you
can just spray them with some spray and
toss them in that kind of like an
everything seasoning yes they actually
have hot wing seasoning so it's powdered
down you know what's so good about this
is it sometimes hummus gets overpowering
and you can have a couple and you're
like H that's too much this feels like
you could eat the whole thing it's like
hummus with a little personality showed
she she showed up and she's ready to
play I I am Shing I'm sharing TI's
napkins Roy this is so gosh darn good I
can't even take it thank you I just
thank you I just know when you're on a
health Journey sometimes um you feel
like you're missing out on some
experiences you know anyone else relate
to that I refuse I'm not going to miss
out on snacking on the big day and now
you don't have to all right enjoy these
all check out my my website too rip.com
for more ideas like this and up next are
you a fan of ketchup and Ranch well
you're not going to believe what we're
about to do with them find
[Applause]
[Music]
out